yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
your data is your business
protect it at expressvpn.com
it's unconscionable that higher
education has gotten two and a half
times more expensive over the last
number of years
and one of the jokes i used to pose was
like has it gotten two and a half times
better and that always got a laugh
because people were like it has not
really gone to that times better
many universities especially elite in
universities have become hedge funds
that
provide classes to the children of their
investors and then we
wipe vaseline over the lens of the cast
structure that has been
that higher education has become by
letting in some freakishly remarkable
middle class and lower income kids
and to try and make ourselves kind of
the neosporin of our guilt
what we could do is through a mix of
small and big tech
potentially potentially dramatically
expand capacity
i was a remarkably unremarkable kid and
the reason i'm here speaking to you
today
is because ucla led in a third of its
applicants
academics and administrators have become
drunk on exclusivity andrew every year
the deans of the top schools including
mine get up and boast that we rejected
88
of our applicants that's tantamount to
the head of a housing shelter
bragging that he or she turned away nine
in 10 people who showed up last night
[Music]
hey guys it's zach grauman i was andrew
yang's campaign manager and one of the
co-hosts of yang speaks on today's
episode we've got scott galloway he's an
nyu professor
and a marketing expert and they talk
about how you actually break up big tech
companies
what to do with our universities today
and all the problems that come with that
they also talk about the crisis of men
scott galloway is one of the smartest
men on the planet
this conversation could have gone on for
hours it's fantastic so sit back relax
and enjoy yang speaks with scott
[Music]
galloway
welcome scott thanks very much andrew
and this is the prop g
show and i want to welcome our guest
andrew yang andrew hasn't been up to
much recently so i don't know what we're
going to talk about
but anyways we're doing this a little
bit different it's a back and forth it's
a
it's a it's one plus one equals three
and we're gonna have a conversation here
but anyways
andrew i will let you kick it off well
scott
your blog is uh something that i
read as a sign of what's coming because
you're like a great combination
of numbers and humanity and you also
are a parent like i am you're concerned
about a lot of the same issues
i am around text impact on our kids
mental health
and you're postulating which i agree
with because it just makes sense that
the tech companies are going to start
moving into education in this next
number of weeks and months in part
because a lot of the universities are
going to be struggling
but in part because the tech companies
have a mandate to grow
and if you're going to try and grow
there are only limited
industries that can afford you a big
enough dollar sign to meaningfully
impact a trillion dollar company
uh so you're a professor your day job in
addition to the five million other
things that you're doing
um and you've written extensively
already on like the future of education
i'd love i'd love to talk about what you
see
as tech's role in the future of
education as someone who's on the inside
uh thanks for that andrew yeah so i i
think if you look at
any public company makes an implicit
promise to shareholders that they'll
double their stock price in five years
otherwise investors will go by zoom or
peloton or something else
so if you're apple or google that means
you've got to grow
your top line assuming some operating
leverage by anywhere between
call it 100 and 200 billion dollars over
the next five years
so if you realistically have to grow
your your top line by 100 to 200 billion
what that means is there's just very few
game you can actually go hunting for
it kind of limits you to 10 industries
the ottoman that are big enough to save
that appetite that top line
appetite you could say well the auto
industry well that's a low margin
difficult business that's already pretty
efficiently run you could say well
government
well okay are these companies going to
start getting into government services
the two obvious ones are health care 17
or 18
of us gdp high margins people aren't
very satisfied
and then education what is a you know a
multi-trillion dollar industry globally
six or seven hundred billion
domestically so i would argue the big
tech
it's not if they'll get into tech it's
when and why because they have to they
have no choice there's very few
industries that offer
just the sheer amount the carcass the
size that can save their appetite so i
think that they will
go into into education in the short term
it will be around supplying tools
as universities are all of a sudden
faced with 20 30 50
in some cases 100 of their classes going
online they'll be serving them as
vendors
you're already seeing these companies
ramp up their educational offerings
and then we might see or we will see i
think them do what google just announced
and that is they'll get into the
business of certification because at the
end of the day
the 240 000 in tuition that nyu
asks households to pay it's yeah it's
for the experience yeah it's for the
education
but the real roi is in the certification
so my question to you
my question back to you andrew on
inauguration day
do you put in place a plan do you fund
the doj and break these guys
up we got to do something for sure and
it's one thing i'd love to talk to you
about is that if you share
our diagnosis of the fact that these
companies
are running roughshod on many things
that you'd consider
the public domain whether it's the way
we get information
or our democracy or again our kids
mental health
like there needs to be a real government
role one of the things that
i said on the trail was like we need
21st century solutions for 21st century
problems
and i'm not sure if you just go around
saying break them up
um that's going to do the trick though
in certain cases 100
a lot of these businesses need to divest
parts of themselves like you shouldn't
have amazon
uh white labeling their own stuff and
then essentially crowding out like other
folks who are trying to sell
uh to consumers you can't have these
companies just gobbling up anything that
could become a potential competitor
even in an adjacent space like if you
had a monopoly in the old days you would
say look
okay you're 18 t or whatever like we're
not going to let you
also just start buying into uh
retail or electronic stores or whatever
whatever the heck it is like
that that's like adjacent to you in the
way that we've let
alphabet just freaking get into anything
under the sun like
they've got like a near quasi monopoly
on
on search engines and advertising and
the rest of it so maybe there needs to
be some limit
but it's bad for innovation it's bad for
us all if the business model
of every company in silicon valley is to
get annoying enough so that
one of the trillion dollar behemoths
will just throw throw some stock at you
and then
like gobble you up uh like and that that
right now is a more realistic
plan for entrepreneurs than it is to say
like i'm going to beat
google i'm going to beat facebook it's
more like i'm going to get just
annoying enough so that they can snap me
up and then you'll be rich i'll be rich
i'll do my earn out i'll hang out in the
bowels and like
you know chill out silicon valley style
um so so that's
not where we should be like that there
are certainly and it needs to be
government i mean it's one thing that
like i appreciate about your perspective
is that the problems are mammoth and
your book the four
laid them out in graphic detail and if
you look around
so many people and i'm an entrepreneur
you're an entrepreneur
um like i like uh
i like people pursuing entrepreneurial
opportunities but the market's not going
to afford any kind of
counterweight to what's going on with
like your kids
you know addiction to screens or my kids
addiction to screens or whatnot like
that
there's not like a market-based solution
and so we have to do the impossible
which is get the government to get it
[ __ ] together
which is like and and as a practical
problem solver
like that's not appealing either in
those sets you're like oh really like i
have to rely on government to do this
thing but yeah we have to rely on
government to do this thing because
there's no
realistic alternative in my opinion well
it's interesting because we have a
at first off you said something that
really resonated i advise a venture
capital firm i'm in a lot of pitches
and essentially every pitch from a small
company to uh
venture capital funders is something
some
variation of the following we don't
compete with
apple amazon facebook and google but
we'd make a great acquisition
so you're right it's no longer about
unseating these behemoths the fastest
growing parts of our economy
devices social media search
social there hasn't been a social media
platform
started of any size since 2011 since
pinterest so the fastest growing parts
of our economy are dominated by these
monopolies and duopolies we like to
think we're in an era of innovation
we're in an era of non-innovation there
were more businesses being started every
day in the carter administration there
are now it used to be 15
of companies we're less than 12 months
old now it's seven percent
so let's i'm curious let's talk about
any trust
we actually have in the u.s a proud
legacy of antitrust we broke up
you know i think it was teddy roosevelt
got elected by the railroad guys and
then turned around and said i love you
but i got to break you up because you're
bad for america we broke up at t we
broke up the aluminum guys
and antitrust is one of the few
government actions that we sort of get
the government gets right all the time
if you look back there's very few
breakups where you look back and think
the government screwed up
yeah we shouldn't have done that yeah
yeah when it happened it was right it's
like the one thing where government's
batting a thousand
why is it that america has fallen out of
love with any trust
i'd say there are three things scott the
first is that the 20th century framework
was built around
uh anti-competitive pricing uh and if
you are the amazons or the googles of
the world you're like
what do you mean like i charge less than
everybody consumer not gouging anyone
and so if you use price as your
framework then there doesn't seem to be
a problem even though there are massive
negative
externalities uh you know that aren't
accounted for and price
uh the second thing is that our
government has now become bought and
sold by
lobbyists and so even though tech was a
little bit late to the game in lobbying
uh like what do you have on the other
side nothing really like you have a
clueless legislature being like well
i don't understand technology and then
you have the tech lobbyists whispering
in their ear being like hey if anything
you need us to you know it quote unquote
innovate more
so that there's not like and and the
third thing
is that i think our entire society has
become collectively brainwashed into
like an efficiency culture
it's like capital efficiency for
ourselves
and you talk about this in some of your
work too like where you know like the
like i'm i'm i think like fairly
efficient but there's there's been this
collective brainwashing of all of us
that
uh that efficiency is good that the tech
companies in particular
enable efficiency and that standing in
their way
is inefficient and hand-in-hand with
that has been this complete mistrust of
government
as this paragon of inefficiency of bloat
bureaucracy
etc and so culturally we are not
disposed towards
trying to break up these tech companies
that we think have improved our lives
particularly in contrast with what we
think about government a lot of the time
now i think that these things are all
wrong
like i think you're right that antitrust
has historically been a real force for
for progress balanced progress not just
extreme progress
and the example that roger mcnamee uses
like look you had these chemical
manufacturing companies it took us a
little while to figure out that dumping
chemicals
like into landfills and streams was
really bad and we needed to regulate it
this industry is relatively new and it's
taken us a little bit of time to realize
just how
noxious for example the advertising
driven revenue model is
for social media and a bunch of other
things but we need to figure it out and
then we need to take affirmative steps
and my great hope for this time is that
we're going to actually embrace
more aggressive ambitious solutions than
we would have considered pre-crisis
that's like the silver lining one thing
i campaigned on was that it's
unconscionable that higher education has
gotten two and a half times more
expensive over the last number of years
and one of the jokes i used to pose was
like has it gotten two and a half times
better and that always got a laugh
because people were like it has not
really gotten two and a half times
better no
and then i posed the question to the
folks in the audience and was like hey
why has it gotten so expensive and then
they think about it for a minute and
then i
say did we hire lots of professors and
they're like no
you know did we build lots of new
buildings and they were like maybe
and then i say that the real driver is
the fact that we've hired
150 more non-faculty administrators
at these universities they've become
these like overgrown
uh bureaucracies themselves and it's
become this hidden tax
on people on the middle class on folks
who are trying to to
uh give their kids a better life and
that's been building up for
decades in part because any any
college every year just looks around and
says okay how
much are we going to increase our prices
by this year and so you have this
this inflationary effect that's unique
to
health care and education and then
families felt like they had no choice
but to pay
so then the government said don't worry
about it we've got you here are some
loans so we're now up to 1.6 trillion in
student loan debt
and i love the fact that you work for
nyu but you're honest about the fact
that look
these university administrators have
very clear financial incentives
like foregoing 400 million dollars in
tuition
is like uh you know like it it would
wreck
um many of these institutions and so you
have many
schools that are bravely putting up uh
signals saying well hey we're going to
reconvene in the fall and then you look
at it and say like
is this what you would do if this wasn't
like an existential problem for your
school to forego
uh tuition revenue for a semester and
i would love to hear your ideas on how
we can somehow
help the university system
become more cost conscious and invest in
things that will actually improve kids
educational outcomes
as opposed to their u.s news and world
report rankings
yeah we are definitely brothers from
another mother i mean we your summary
it took me two years to get to the to
the
summary you just articulated in about
three minutes but
look we live in a capitalist society and
having more money means more opportunity
for your kids access to better health
care
access to a broader selection of mates
it's just a wonderful thing to have
more versus less money in a capitalist
society and all of us fall
victim to that in the sense that when
it's
you're first and foremost going to fix
your own oxygen mass and there's a
belief that
universities are these very noble
institutions where we wear cardigans
watch pbs and pet our labrador and don't
think about money
and professors and administrators want
the same economic security as everyone
else
so by a combination of this dictum or
this gestalt where everybody has to get
a college education
where we constrain supply and become
luxury brands as opposed to public
servants
we consistently have been able to raise
prices through this kind of cartel
as you mentioned twice as fast as
inflation and we justify that we're
doing it for the right reasons but the
reality is
many universities especially elite in
universities have become hedge funds
that
provide classes to the children of their
investors and then we
wipe vaseline over the lens of the cast
structure that has been
that higher education has become by
letting in some freakishly remarkable
middle class and lower income kids
and to try and make ourselves kind of
the neosporin of our guilt this
is it's it's it's morally corrupt
and it is it is the spring used to be a
time of nervousness but excitement about
where your kid was going to college
now it's become despair and anxiety
around
how do i tell my little girl that on a
fireman's salary and maybe my wife is
my wife is a doctor a nurse that we
can't afford to send her
to tulane how do you have that
conversation how do you
how do you feel like you're failing the
american dream
because you can't afford to after
working your ass off to income
you can't afford to send or you make a
worse decision and that is your kid
doesn't get into the top school because
they take pride in rejecting nine out of
ten applicants
and worst yet they go to a second tier
school where they don't get nearly the
upside because
corporations still look at those
universities in terms of evaluating your
currency in the marketplace and how much
they're going to pay you
but you incur elite university level
debt it's just this is one of the most
in my opinion
ugly parts of our society right now and
it's happened incrementally because like
anyone else
university administrators and professors
want to live the same great life
as anyone else what what do we do about
it i've been spending a lot of time with
chancellor block who is the
chancellor of the of my alma mater that
receives more applications than any
university in the world and that's the
university of california los angeles
and i've come to the conclusion that
these institutions are almost
constitutionally incapable of cutting
costs between tenure between the rolex
vacation of their facilities
it is very hard for them and they
haven't had to cut costs for 40 years
it's almost impossible what we could do
is through a mix of small and big tech
potentially potentially dramatically
expand capacity
if you were to take 50 of your courses
online and there are a lot of courses
that would be fine online or a lot of
sessions
where there isn't a lot of interaction
that you could facilitate online if you
take half your classes online
you effectively andrew double the size
of the campus
so what i would like to see and what i
would hope individuals like you that
might serve in a cabinet
or be in a position of of authority and
power someday is could we have some sort
of grand bargain where we go to
governors let's go to governor newsom
and say
increase the university of california
budget by 20 and we're going to
dramatically decrease the cost per
student educated through the use of
small and big tech by expanding our
capacity
and we're going to take ucla back from a
13 admit rate to where it was in the 90s
20 or 25. we have to dramatically expand
our land-grant public universities
capacity such that
we can take good maybe not remarkable i
mean i don't know where you went to
school i was a remarkably unremarkable
kid and the reason i'm here speaking to
you today
is because ucla led in a third of its
applicants
and they could say to the son of a
single immigrant mother who lived and
died as secretary
let's be honest you're not great but we
like your profile you're a
son of amer of california we're going to
let you in they don't have the luxury of
doing that now
they don't have the luxury of letting in
kids with remarkable futures they have
to only let in the remarkable so i think
it's about
dramatically expanding through the use
of technology
freshman seats and also breaking this
wheel
where academics and administrators have
become drunk on exclusivity andrew every
year
the deans of the top schools including
mine get up and boast that we rejected
88
of our applicants that's tantamount to
the head of a housing shelter
bragging that he or she turned away nine
in ten people who showed up last night
we
have lost the script we need to move
back to being public servants
as opposed to luxury brands we need to
embrace technology
and have almost like a martial martial
act act-like feel
such that we take capacity for our great
public systems university of texas
michigan
university of california cal state cuny
florida state systems
and drama and expand their seats by 30
or 50 percent i think a crisis is a
terrible thing to waste i think there's
an
opportunity here to move back to where
we were where kids who are unremarkable
have remarkable opportunities through
the upward lubricant that is
higher ed anyways that's my rant andrew
that's my rant
i love your rant and i love the fact too
that you're putting your
your time into making that happen
because i saw you offer something like
an mba sprint
where you're and you're one of like the
top rated uh professors at
nyu's business school and you said wait
a minute i can actually give
a suit in like a significant proportion
of the value
at a fraction of the the cost and this
is something
there's something you you may not know
about me i used to run
the nation's largest gmat prep company
manhattan
gmat oh yeah yeah and and like i
i saw the same thing you did which is
like why is a mid-professional
20-something-year-old taking two years
out and spending 100k
plus on an mba and it was like is it
the course work it's like and not really
like some of them actually took some of
the same coursework
um as undergrads or learn something
equivalent like during their analyst
program or whatnot
it's like uh is it that credentialing
heck yes it's like they want that
credential and then be able to like
have this career transition to have
their hand stamped
as someone that amazon or google or
morgan stanley would want to hire and
then i thought it's like does that
should that take two years and 100 000
plus
like like could you actually kind of
compress the credentialing
if you had essentially an analogous
admissions process
and an analogous like brand attached to
it
where and so my my thought process was
like instead of
a two-year mba program at uh columbia or
hbs or whatnot if mckinsey said hey
this is going to be like the mckinsey
summer at sea
and uh it's instead of a hundred
thousand it's
25 000 and you'll get a mckinsey
credential right and it takes
like uh three months and we give you a
lot of the same social experiences that
you expect out of uh
out of your mba program because a lot of
it's the network you show up you
commingle with people that you think are
going to be uh both friends and
uh you know good colleagues and
corporate contacts
and then i thought to myself do you
really need to be in the same place with
folks for
like two academic years uh you know
broken up by a summer or could you build
those relationships faster
so like the fact that you're actually
experimenting with this kind of format
is like we have to come clean about the
fact that uh look
and this is something you argue is like
look a lot of these schools are
essentially just becoming cast system
organizers
uh and it's not like when a parent gets
um you know or not when the kid gets the
admissions letter
from the school the parent is then like
oh that's great because here are like
the 10 professors i want you to study
with like they're not
actually paying attention at that level
they just know the brand of the school
and so that's right if you so if we can
like we we need to examine this from
soup to nuts like you look at and say
okay
why is it four years why does it cost
this much
and to your point like why are you
getting rewarded for turning people down
like
aren't you supposed to be a public good
i love the fact that you've identified
public universities as the place to
launch this from because it makes the
most sense
and and they should be growing their
seats like instead of
a proportion of people you reject
it should be looking up society-wide and
saying okay how many
18-year-olds do we think are like
approximately
the right fit for what we're going for
in terms of a public education
and then you should be rewarded for
educating a higher proportion of those
people
which is like the reverse of the way
they get rewarded now yeah
if i'm in position to do this man i'm
100 gonna do it you're in you're in
because
yeah like it comes down to a a basic
theme in a shift in mindset and that is
the
the worth of a society isn't the
opportunities it offers it's remarkable
it feels to me like the united states
and i'm curious to get your has moved
from
how do we give our truly remarkable
remarkable being people who are born
with
tremendous opportunities and also are
tremendously skilled
you know everyone says nyu is a place
for rich kids yeah
but it's also rich kids who are super
impressive they're remarkable
do we just continue to funnel more and
more of the spoils to that small segment
who are both blessed
because they're born into wealth and be
very good remarkable
or isn't the judge of a society or the
worth of a society
what kind of opportunities it gives to
it's unremarkable what kind of
opportunities it gives to the kid
who maybe doesn't have access to the
test prep that you are offering who
maybe
has had challenges at home who maybe
doesn't at the age of 15 doesn't have a
patent
and isn't building wells in africa and
isn't captain of the lacrosse team
i mean the kids that now get into these
schools we're basically saying that the
two
the two cohorts that are going to divide
the spoils of of american productivity
wages have not gone up
productivity skyrocketed that's
trillions of dollars in surplus
wealth that all goes to two cohorts
that's the children of rich kids or
people who are freakishly remarkable
between the ages of 15 and 17 who get
into harvard
we talk about these elite schools the
reason we talk i talk about the state
schools is
the ivs are more spectacle than historic
they educate they have 64 000 total
students
ohio state has 55 000. florida state has
75 000 berkeley will
graduate more kids from a low-income
household this year than the entire ivy
league combined so the ivy league
look fine you're you're great leaders
produce leaders
children's of rich kids and remarkable
kids from middle and lower income
households
but where america changes where men are
fundamentally changes
is these land-grant public schools that
educate two-thirds
two-thirds of our students and we're
going to need some sort of real dramatic
rethinking i think this is your platform
i think ubi
and education i think these are the two
legs of the stool i don't know what the
third one is andrew
for your next run you you'd have to say
health care everyone you have to say
hell because healthcare has some of the
similar problems to
education you're going to like this
about me scott my parents met
at uc berkeley like they integrated cow
yeah
yeah yeah they immigrated uh from taiwan
and met on campus
my brother is named after the lawrence
observatory he was born
where did you go to school i went to
brown
got it and in and so let me ask you this
so
christina paxton i think her name is the
president of brown
makes a very bold authoritative
statement in the spring that we have a
national obligation to welcome back
students
i think she's looking at her bank
account when she says that i think we
have an obligation
to keep kids at home right now given the
spike in the virus i think it is
irresponsible to think that
the kids who basically go to college to
not distance
are going to maintain the same on-campus
protocols off campus
and that these strident statements that
we should welcome students back to
campus
are i don't want to use the word
negligent but don't acknowledge the
reality of the virus
and are loosely influenced by
the notion that these institutions have
been used to taking one 200 3 million
300 million dollars in tuition deposits
and for them to say
we're brown and we want to charge you 58
000 but it's going to be for a bunch of
zoom classes from your
your your dad's office or your old
bedroom that your dad's converted into
an office
that they are being unduly influenced by
money
and that we're setting ourselves up
universities to be the new super
spreaders it used to be nursing homes
and it used to be i would call
republican
arrogant governors have been the agents
of super spread i'm worried it's going
to move to chancellors and
event the new venues of super spread in
september are going to be universities
and president paxson
has an obligation to come out and say we
are not going to welcome you back you
need to stay at home
your thoughts i'd say two things number
one i tend to listen more closely of
someone saying something against their
uh self-interest or in their
institutions interests
so if you have a couple hundred million
on one side of the ledger
and you say hey i'm going to pound the
the table for that side of the ledger
then i tend to
like discount it or just be like yeah of
course you'd say that because you've got
a couple hundred million steering you
that direction
if someone heads the opposite direction
then i'm like ooh like this person
actually is uh speaking on principle
or evincing leadership because it's
against the grain one thing i disagree
with you about is you said like the ivy
league's producing a bunch of leaders
um you know i did the math like 80
percent of the folks out of the ivy
league schools will do one of six things
in six places
uh banking consulting law tech
medicine or academia in new york san
francisco boston chicago
dc or la and and if you do the same
thing that everyone else does
to me it's not exactly the definition of
leadership yeah it's like
it's like it's like hey i'm just gonna
like you know hop in the stream and then
like
swim where the current takes me and then
uh and then
cash in my like the water that sprinkles
on me because i'm now
attached to this geyser of uh surplus
so um so that number one is look if your
economic incentives are to say something
and you say that thing then it's like
well
like you know maybe i should take that
with like a man with grain of salt the
second thing is when you talk about
educators who have an obligation to
their kids to say hey we need to reopen
school
you're looking at kids who are at an
earlier stage of formative development
are there kids who legitimately are
going to be damaged if they
don't have some kind of real like
educational different ball of acts you
have kids i have a nine and a 12 year
old i think the conversation around
reopening schools for them is an
entirely different conversation than
whether a 19 year old
needs to get back to chapel hill i think
it's a totally different conversation
agree that 19 year olds relatively fully
formed like having
like a period of time uh like in you
your pro gap year i'm
also very pro gap year so if you have
people who are
18 or 19 years old doing something
independent that's probably good for
their development like
you know like like saying that hey i
need to get them back on campus asap
because
uh like the kids are gonna get screwed
up if they're not here it's like
like i'm not as worried about kids
missing like
you know intro to lit classes as i am
like the the third grader who's not
going to be able to read
you know like that that's like the the
bigger
problem um so i'm with you i'm aligned
um yeah i haven't talked to
uh president paxton about uh
yeah we haven't reached out to her and
told her to stop stop that
[Music]
[Applause]
here at yang speaks we think that our
data should be ours and right now our
data is getting harvested right and left
by tech companies marketers data brokers
and one way you can change that is by
using expressvpn
vpn stands for virtual private network
which is fancy corporate speak
for it's like you're on the internet
someplace else so they can't find you
you could be
like you know out of country you know
what's wild is netflix actually has
different shows and movies
like the betting is true so it's like
you're logging in in italy or whatnot
and sometimes you'll get some different
programming
now there are lots of vpns out there but
expressvpn
is top rated by wired and others
it's ridiculously fast you hit a button
and then essentially it's like you're
logged on
someplace else where no one can find you
and so if this is something that you
want to make part of your
internet hygiene you can use our link
right now at expressvpn.com
yang get an extra three months of
express
vpn for free that's expressvpn.com
yang so you can surf safely and
in the privacy of your own habits
without anyone looking over your
shoulder
honestly i really love this thing
because i'm not
good at installing apps or little
widgets or trinkets on the computer but
expressvpn dude you just literally press
a button
it's fantastic i can't i can't i've i'm
unable to screw it up which i love
so check it out we get a good discount
with us expressvpn.com
yang
[Applause]
so i i i wanna i to know more about
i'm just fascinated i can't i can't
figure out if you're the
most or the least self-aware pres uh a
person to decide to run for president i
can't decide if this
is that you're either delusional
or you have just incredible
self-awareness and courage
what when you decided to run for
president
like when you think out well let me back
up what was the best
be more specific what was the best and
the worst thing about running for
president
the best thing is going someplace and
having people
excited to see me excited for the
campaign investing
uh their hopes for the future in me
and my run and that's something that
you can't anticipate really and you
certainly can't anticipate what it's
like in real life when you show up and
there is like the mom
or the uh nurse or the school teacher or
the union worker
it's got to be very rewarding personally
yeah so so that that was the
best part are your parents still alive
andrew
yeah yeah they are happily thank
goodness for that i haven't seen them in
a while because they're kind of older i
can't imagine how rewarding it must be
and i imagine they got to events
to see your parents seeing you
ignite a conversation nationally have
people show up who buy into their son
that just must have been
so remarkably rewarding for you and for
them
yeah i brought my family closer together
particularly when my
uh wife and kids joined me on the trail
in the later
stages and so the worst part was i
didn't see my kids a whole lot for
two years really because i was on the
trail so much and like i would just
parachute back in
and that was hard because my boys now
are seven and four so you know you
remember those ages
yeah um yeah in terms of what what drove
me to run scott
uh you're an entrepreneur and so
it's like you see that there's like a
need in the market like
they're the things that you and i care
about and care about deeply care about
the future
uh and you know no one's gonna do [ __ ]
about it really
like you you look up and say like
especially if you've had the fortune
or misfortune of meeting those people
which i had done
like i've been around senators and
governors and presidents
and i was like no one's gonna do [ __ ]
all about like some of the biggest
things coming down the road
uh and so you knew this uh you fancy
yourself
a problem solver and entrepreneur and
also a patriot and a parent
and you look up and say there is no
plausible way that this is going to get
addressed unless
someone runs for president advances
these ideas mainstreams them gets them
to a point where
they have a an accelerated timeline and
possibility of getting past
and then you have the belief that you
might be able to actually advance
those ideas yeah then to me it actually
would have been
a very very petty decision not to run uh
because
if you think you might be able to do
that and you're like yeah like i'll go
you know like run some startup somewhere
and like pad my bank account then you're
kind of an [ __ ]
yeah and so so so to me really like the
question
i had to face is like am i going to just
like
live with myself being a total [ __ ]
or am i going to do something about it
um and i looked at my downsides and i
said like what are my downsides
time away from my family money uh total
humiliation
um you know like and i looked at it and
it's like i can live with these things
you know it's like you know and part of
it too is like growing up the
the first generation uh you know son of
immigrants
in uh in the 70s like
i got humiliated a lot
as a kid so i'm so i'm not someone who
is like
scared of looking ridiculous uh because
you know like you build up some um yeah
some thick skin around that
if you'd experience that somewhat
regularly as a kid
yeah nothing really wonderful happens to
you without taking an uncomfortable risk
and it's when you were describing that
[ __ ] that's been focused on money and
not public service
you know that's me and i i admire people
like you
that are sort of hitting you're kind of
hitting your prime
income earning years and i have
unfortunately and i'm
i'm smart enough to recognize it i don't
know if i'm
have the integrity or the courage to do
anything about it
but i grew up with no money and i
decided very early on
that i was going to develop economic
security and then quite frankly and i'm
not proud of this i've become a little
bit drunk with status and power
the status and power that money affords
you and the lifestyle and i've been very
focused on money
and i've always had a great deal of
admiration for people who
decide that okay i've gotten to a
certain level of comfort i'm going to
stop howling in the money storm
and i'm going to start trying to give
back and and add value and it's
something i don't like about myself
what advice would you have for people
who are
caught in this hamster wheel
if i want the bigger house i want the
second house i don't want to fly
business class i want to fly
i want my own plane someday i want you
know i want that i think a capitalist
society is just so much about economic
security and all my friends who are
entrepreneurs and all the wealthy people
i know who claim they don't care about
money or obsess with money anyone who
says they don't
care about money is obsessed with it or
that's what i found
how do you how do you get to a point
where you say all right
i'm going to focus on the country i'm
going to focus on service what
you know was there a moment when you
said this is this is
this is what i'm about and i'm going to
kind of step off the
the hamster wheel i had a couple of
advantages
uh one is growing up the children of
immigrants like
you're kind of used to things not being
great
guess like we had like you know like the
and it was fine i mean i had like a
like a you know quality uh middle class
uh
upbringing environment but uh there's
like a scrappiness where like you're not
at least my folks were not really driven
by like nice stuff
um and the other advantage was that as
an entrepreneur
my income level was so volatile that
like i'd make
a lot in one year and then like nothing
the next year and so as a result you
just became like okay
uh like even if their times are good let
me not
spend every dollar and like have my
lifestyle get better let me just like
find like a
a level that i'm comfortable with um
so so those were a couple of the big
advantages i had and i don't begrudge
folks who
you know are like pursuing market based
success
um in my case and my joke with my wife
that it was sort of a bait and switch
scott because like i was like a fairly
normal
uh ceo operator guy um when she and i
met and started dating and then after my
company was bought
um i turned around and was like hey i'm
sick of seeing all of the nations
not all but like a lot of the nations
like ambitious energetic types do
stuff that i know is not going to
actually do on anyone any good and it's
probably going to turn them into
miserable human beings and [ __ ] over
time um so
so one one advantage was that like i
spent five
uh unhappy months as a corporate
attorney in my twenties um and
and i thought it was like the worst
thing in the world i i joked that
my uh firm was like a temple to the
squandering of human potential
uh and so like i took like a massive
pay cut to start a com that flopped out
of that time
yeah um and my parents everyone was like
what are you doing you know it was a six
figure job and i was like no i'm gonna
do this thing and then my startup died
and
like i still owed 100k in law school
loans which is one reason why
i'm passionate about the fact that we're
loading these kids up with debt
because i carried my debt around for um
like a decade or more i used to call it
my mistress because it was like i was
writing a check to like a family in
another
town i was like like i hope sally mae is
having a good life and like
yeah you know wherever it is so
so all those things together uh just
made me you know it's like
i was just trying to pursue
opportunities um that i thought
and you know i'm not like i'm not a
saint in the sense that's like
oh like let me do this i find the work
interesting i'll meet some great people
i have a chance to work with smart
people i admire and respect
uh you know like i just wanted to do
work i was pumped about
um and the work i was pumped about was
work that
uh was a bit more service-oriented
uh like when i started the non-profit
and that was like i joke with evelyn my
wife it's like
what what do you think was harder
starting that non-profit of running for
president she was like oh starting
adventure for america for sure
like like when you turn around and say
i'm gonna start a non-profit and not
like the
the like i'm gonna write a check and
then become the chairman and then float
away like i was like
i'm gonna be the founder ceo
no salary just gut it out like
make this thing happen and venture for
america scott did something i think
you'd really love
like we recruited and enlist and we do
do to this day very successfully
i'm recruiting enlist enterprising and
ambitious
college grads who want to learn how to
become entrepreneurs and then we
send them to work at early stage
companies in new orleans detroit
baltimore
cleveland other cities around the
country and then we have a seed fund to
invest in them after a two year
fellowship like i know you're very
interested in this idea of national
service like you proposed a corona core
for uh 18 to 22 year olds to go out and
contact trace i had to say my uh the
same
general idea in 2011 um and then i quit
my job and started a non-profit
service corps uh for entrepreneurship
because of what you said earlier which
is that entrepreneurship's dying in the
united states
and i thought it was dying even more
dramatically in rust belt cities
and the southeast and so i spent six and
a half years
trying to solve for that um and
i thought that our meritocracy was
dementing our people
so i was going to duke and
uh you know other campuses being like
hey instead of becoming a toolbox banker
consultant why don't you learn to become
an entrepreneur
and move to detroit for two years and
then these
these kids took me up on it um and you
know and it
so that was the work i did for for six
and a half years
um and then i realized that [ __ ] was
broken at a much higher level and there
was no way to
fix it except to have the government
rewrite our economy in different ways
and then that led me to run for
president
um so that was a long-winded answer as
to how i
wound up doing what i'm doing like i i
see myself
as just someone who wants to do work i'm
passionate about
but what okay so let me lead you into
another question and that is
what you have ideas you clearly have
you're a unique thinker i think coming
out of the presidential election if they
said who has the most unique
most creative ideas you would win you
would you would be at the top of that
poll
what is the most effective platform for
you over the next couple of years
and is it to be in the cabinet position
is it to run for governor or a senate or
is it to position yourself
for another run in four years like what
is
or as a media personality what is the
platform
that helps you get the most traction
around these ideas
i'm just trying to solve the problems in
real time and this is a catastrophic
time in the country so i'm going to be
attracted to whatever
position helps me make the most impact
right now i want joe to win and
we've been having conversations about
joining the cabinet in a
technology-facing role
yeah uh something to try and address
some of the issues that we and i talked
about earlier on
uh yeah i just want to do good work man
it's like it's what you know
what drives me um certainly i'm very
open to running for
office again because i've learned now
more than ever that
we need to speed up that our government
is not designed to solve these problems
in a meaningful way
and you talked about the incentives of
university administrators the incentives
of politicians
are not actually to like make big
changes or solve problems either
it's to accrue resources and political
capital
um avoid uh scandalous press coverage
because you did something
you know like reprehensible or like you
harass someone or like you know
like like something awful like and that
that i pretty much listed all of your
incentives like
like it's not like hey did you actually
address
the imbalances in our education system
that have been building up for
generations
no it's like are you actually going to
address the tech platforms that are now
um more powerful than our government in
many respects are having a bigger impact
on our life it's like no it's like
they're not actually being judged on the
merits of
the government's performance which is
one reason why everyone's
and look at what this pandemic i mean
like we we are the biggest
uh fiasco globally in terms of our
ability to handle this because
uh of like our failed government
and a lot of people will put that at the
feet of donald trump which
he deserves certainly like a whole lot
of credit but there were failures at
every level of government you look at
the cdc's decisions like that there were
a lot of embarrassing
uh bureaucratic missteps there fda same
thing like you know
we had the like months to try and build
up testing and contact tracing
and it hasn't worked so
yeah so this is uh this is the challenge
man it's like
it's like a turnaround where if you came
upon like a really big organization like
the ucs and you looked up and you said
hey these people are constitutionally
unable to
cut costs like what the hell do we do
here it's a little bit like that where
you get to the government
and you're like okay like these people
are constitutionally unable to do
anything that's against their political
interest like
[Laughter]
what do we do with this um and so so
like one of the things i have to do is i
have to make it so that it's in people's
political interest to solve problems
and the most obvious problem right now
is that there are tens of millions of
americans who do not have
enough money to like get through the
next number of weeks and months 74
percent of americans think emergency
cash relief is a good idea
like tens of millions of americans got
twelve hundred dollars in
cash uh in april and they loved it so
so this is like my lever right now is
like okay what's the big problem i can
solve that
we'll try and align the interest of
politicians with the people
cash relief universal basic income
education i think will be very effective
because
middle class americans and aspiring
americans are fed up with the fact that
like you said they look up and say how
the hell is college sixty thousand
dollars like that makes no sense
um so so we we have to just keep on
trying to find these like leverage
points
um but i hope to be in position where i
can actually start pulling policy levers
sometime the next number of uh months
because like the problems are getting
worse unfortunately
and you to me are one of the key uh
thinkers on actually
speaking honestly and uh
bluntly about just how severe a lot of
these problems are
[Music]
[Applause]
so yang i when i was a kid my brother
used to have this t-shirt
and it was just a bunch of soccer balls
on it and on a
on a plate with a fork and knife and it
said eat your veg to balls
and for some reason i always think of
athletic greens
when i always think of that shirt when i
think of athletic greens
because you're supposed to eat your
vegetables but in my case eat your
vegetables which is a dumb segue into
this ad for athletic greens
well we're all we're all in our houses
more than normal
uh we might be cooking more than normal
or
eating poorly more than normal hey man
i've i've gained everybody's gained like
the kovid
10 to 30. in my opinion some like
if you're if you've been working out
excessively and eating really healthy
like
kudos to you you're a superstar in this
i said a while ago that anyone who
maintains
a higher level of physical fitness
during this time should just get more
responsibility because they're like the
most disciplined yes
self-directed person they should be
promoted they should be hired in our
government
all of it yes yes there are new leaders
and one way to
put yourself in that category is through
athletic greens
because you drink it it's energy
it's healthy it's nourishing it feels
great
you're getting your body all this stuff
that you know it's not getting otherwise
you know like it like it's not in ritz
crackers
[Laughter]
i mean like it's not in the pizza i've
been ordering
yes even when you throw veggies on that
pizza it's still
not doing the trick uh so athletic
greens does do the trick it's a life
changer
i've got it in front of me right now
drank it this morning
whether you're trying to get more energy
have your
gut health improve which is really
important your immune system
if you go to athleticgreens.comyang we
got a special offer receive the free
dsk ii wellness bundle with your first
purchase that's up to a one-year supply
of vitamin d as added value
when you try their delicious and
comprehensive daily all-in-one drink
so go to athleticgreens.com yang
and you know you'll feel better in no
time if you order this stuff and start
making it part of your everyday routine
a lot of these things actually taste
nasty and athletic greens i can say
objectively taste pretty good like i
throw it a little water and chug it it
tastes great
so you get the free d3 k2 wellness
bundle which is basically
like hyper athletic greens that they're
gonna throw on top of your order which
is a pretty
awesome deal it's a year supply of
vitamin d to throw in there so check it
out
athleticgreens.com
[Applause]
[Music]
so if there's a chief innovation officer
position in the cabinet and you get that
obviously that would be a a great
platform
what if what if that doesn't happen what
if trump's reelected or biden chooses
someone else for that role
what what is that platform though i
don't even know where you live would you
ever consider running for governor or
senate and if so where would that be and
what would the role be
you and i are neighbors scott i actually
like my
i have a place on the west side of
manhattan oh yeah so
like that's where my kids are signed up
to go to school in new york city
um you know in in the fall would you
ever consider a run against schumer or
cuomo
i mean people are asking me to consider
various uh new york-based runs
um like that there was like a campaign
to draft me to run for mayor there's uh
you know there are people who are
looking to have me
run for other offices in in new york
that just feels kind of right as rain
yang for mayor what's wrong with that
why wouldn't you do that
we're going to look at it for sure i
mean right now
my focus is on helping joe win and try
and address some of the nation scale
problems
yeah but yeah like we're looking at
different things
uh the the key thing is like i'm driven
by the same things i was driven by when
i decided to run for president which is
we have these massive problems
our political class is generally not up
for it
uh and so we have to change it as
quickly as we can i'm in
[Laughter]
i've never been to gracie mansion or
whatever it's called yeah you know
i think that just all you know you hear
something and you try it on and it just
it just feels right so i'm curious i
just have a couple
i apologize i'm asking all the questions
here but um oh fine
what um you were on the trail with all
the candidates so just
give me a sense for who is
obviously excluding yourself of all the
candidates you are exposed to
whose score is the highest on an iq test
who is just by
traditional smarts the smartest person
who ran for president on the democratic
side
it's exactly who you think like that the
folks who come across as really really
uh cognitively loaded when you have
conversations with them
uh are elizabeth warren p buddha judge
uh bernie like uh bernie's
very strong um so those are the folks
that
i think most people would expect you
know if you just were to throw
who's the most likable when the cameras
are off who's the most likable who would
you who do you see and you kind of
can't help but smile or think i'd like
to hang out with that person
you know who who's genuinely a very warm
likable guys
joe biden honestly and that was before i
i had any kind of national reputation
like joe was always warm to me
um you know great to my wife like he's
he he's joe like he actually comes
across like that in real life too
backstage who would you who do you think
joe should pick as his veep
i don't know some of the people that
he's considering uh
but the folks that we know he's
considering that i spend time with like
kamala would be very strong
i i was at an event with tammy duckworth
recently and uh she'd be excellent
um so i certainly don't have like they
call you and they ask for one name who's
your one name who do you think they
should pick as veep
so i genuinely think this has to be a
joe decision because
uh he has to work you sound like a
politician you sound not
you don't sound like the mayor of new
york give me a name
it's genuine man because like you know
if if i were to say to you like hey who
you know
who you're going to like saddle like
next to you for x period of time it's
like yo it's going to be up to you i
know that sounds like a [ __ ]
political answer
but but it's also genuine because you
know you got like joe has to live with a
person
yeah i don't know though it seems like a
lot of presidents and vice presidents
haven't liked each other
that it's more of a calculated political
decision around who who's going to help
him
um who's going to help him win
i i think joe is going to win like by
the numbers
um and i i think he could choose frankly
just about anyone acceptable
and he'd still be the prohibitive
favorite
so so expanding education for sure if i
were to put you in charge just to like
uh
have this turn around given the excesses
we both see
if there were a couple of big policies
that you'd love to see
in place let's say i'm the secretary of
innovation and then i call you up and
say all right scott
let's solve some problems you'd be like
okay here would be like my
you know two or three top priorities
i think we need to start taxing
endowments so universities that don't
grow
their freshman seats faster than
population growth that means they're no
longer public servants or non-profits
they're luxury brands
it's ridiculous that harvard has the
endowment of the gdp of norway and has
decided to constrict
supply that means they're no longer in
the business of public
service they're in the business of being
hermes and they should be
which is their i believe in private
property it's their decision
but they should be considered a private
enterprise and they should be taxed
um i like that you're not going to
believe this yeah one of the policies i
ran on
was the harvard tax which as i said if
you happen to have an endowment over 25
billion which is only one school it was
harvard
then you need to invest like all of the
gains from your endowment in a new
campus in uh one of these states and it
was like ohio michigan florida i mean
because my joke was that it's like how
the hell are you opening a shanghai
campus
and not like uh i agree you know saginaw
campus i went out like it
like it didn't make any sense because
because we're subsidizing you to the
tune of billions of dollars so anyway
just want to let you know it's like you
wouldn't you wouldn't believe it but
like
you know i actually had something called
the harvard tax on the books but you're
right we should do it to every school
and i think stanford's now above 25
billion dollars but i love that why
isn't stanford opening
a satellite campus in mississippi yeah
indeed
they can they call me and say stanford's
applications have tripled in the last
30 years they haven't increased their
freshman class size 1
because again we're all drunk on
exclusivity and want to be the person
with the degree that no one else can get
but i love the idea and they stay
claimed that they're space constrained
which they might be because the
you know the the palo alto community
board doesn't want them to
build more buildings and increase
traffic but why wouldn't they need to if
if nyu can have something in abu dhabi
and wharton can have something in
singapore
then why wouldn't stanford or harvard
have have something in detroit
or you know in in some of the more lower
income or harder hit
communities i think that's a fantastic
idea i think the second thing we need
is class traders what do i mean by that
i think we need deans who are going to
stop awarding tenure i think tenure i
think there are certain
departments in universities that need
the protection from the current
administration
or you know are saying provocative even
sometimes
on you know distasteful things the basic
notion of tenure is that
you know if you say the world isn't flat
you don't get burned at the stake and
you have intellectual freedom
but the reality is andrew at a place
like the business school where i work we
haven't said anything that interesting
in 30 years
recommended changes to gap accounting
are not that controversial
and tenure has gone from protecting a
thought and provoking a conversation
to basically the world's most expensive
guild and union
that creates a total lack of
accountability and expense
that directly translates to debt on
young people so i think we're going to
need some class traders to say
we have to hold ourselves accountable we
have to get more efficient
we have to lower our cost structure i
like the idea of
incorporating big and small tech to
dramatically expand
enrollments i like the idea of having
state systems
have a hybrid model where you go to cal
state or
a junior college for two years and then
to
a name brand school thereby cutting
costs by about 40 percent
and i think we need i think we need a
dramatic
dramatic uh cooper uh grand bargain with
state
and local governments it says look we
need you to
if you increase our budget by 20 we'll
increase our enrollments by 50 percent
and take it back
take take the university system back to
where it needs to be and that is the
greatest upward lubricant
of the middle class as opposed to the
vehicle for casting so i think there's a
i think there's a ton of opportunity i
think it comes down to obviously will
resources creativity
but it's um it's something i'm
passionate about i think it's
i think there's a i think the crisis
presents a tremendous opportunity
i mean you realize andrew in the next 12
months these high tuition high
experience kind of
low brand or high acceptance rate
universities and there's hundreds if not
thousands of them across the us
they could be to education where what
department stores are to retail
we could have a thousand universities
begin a death march starting
september 1. and that's upsetting that's
going to be chaos but there's an
opportunity
to rethink certification education
um you know it's it's going to take big
thinking it's going to take bold ideas
unfortunately we have so many dumpster
fires that it doesn't feel like the kind
of thing we can focus on
uh so hopefully if you know when biden
gets re-elect or gets elected
it'll free us up to not focus on all the
agita all the hate all the [ __ ] and
we can start
focusing on some of these problems right
now it just feels like everyone's just
way too distracted
um the comparison between these
universities and department stores i
think is really powerful and apt and
compelling
and one of the things i said on the
trail is like look
these malls don't just disappear they
become these derelict ghost malls
that that are toxic to environments they
depress
property values they become havens for
uh crime that they
are what i call negative infrastructure
where they go from having positive value
to negative value really quickly
if you have these campuses around the
country that have the lights
go out it's the same thing where you'd
have
infrastructure go from being very
valuable to being
very very depressive uh in
days or weeks so it makes sense to me
that we need to do
something to try and repurpose some of
these physical plants and institutions
to do something
that we need because you look up and say
of course we're going to need more
education for more people
what what you said it is
correct that you're going to have the
winner take all economy play out in
education as well
where it's like why am i going to pay
top dollar for this
lesser institution lesser credential
when
ucla is going to come up with this
hybrid offering that
i can then take advantage of and it's
going to be more efficient and like a
better credential
and so to me
we have to do something with like the
hundreds of schools that are going to
shut their doors
you know it's like there is an
opportunity but it is going to be a
situation where the rich get richer and
the poor get poorer
and and in some cases the poor getting
poorer are going to be institutions like
historically black
colleges and universities you know they
have like skeletal endowments
and like it like if anyone's going to
take a hit
and not be able to survive unfortunately
it's it's uh some of those institutions
um so it's another area where like you
said you're like you need massive
rethinking and
investment and there's there are only
two plausible sources number one
philanthropy which in my case in my
opinion is a bust like it's not going to
be at that scale
like maybe like you said um some of
these schools will be able to turn to
their alumni and say hey bail us out
bail us out like you know you'll have a
couple survive on that basis
but it really has to be the public
sector again and there does need to be a
grand bargain
the problem is that these schools uh
have haven't had to pay a price
and if you're um an institution where
like you've only known one direction and
you've been able to like you know
ratchet up prices
you are as you said constitutionally
unable to turn around and say okay it's
time to get ruthless
like you know these 10 amazing vice
deans or whatever
like four of you have to go you know you
turn the professor and say like hey
um your your teaching loads about to go
up and then you turn to the other person
they're just not like a lot of these
institutions would
shut down before they would make those
kinds of decisions
[Music]
a lot of people listening to yang speaks
are entrepreneurs
and run businesses and right now every
small business has to do more with less
a lot of folks are having a lot of
dynamism in like your
you know ability to find people like
maybe some folks like uh
can't work well one way you can find
workers
really quickly and reliably is
indeed.com it's the number one website
in the world
for finding folks fast we used it on the
campaign
and it works it's one of those things
where you know in some of these markets
uh like that there becomes like a
clearinghouse that
folks know on both sides it's like
employers know it
workers know it and that's what
indeed.com really has become
where you have 73 of online job seekers
visiting indeed every month so if you're
looking for someone they're more likely
to be on indeed it's just the way this
stuff works
and right now indeed is offering our
listeners a free 75
credit to boost your job post which
means more
candidates will see it so try indeed out
with a free 75 dollar credit
at indeed.com yang this is the best
offer
available anywhere go right now to
indeed.com
yang this offer is valid through
september 30th and terms and conditions
apply
[Music]
i'm curious so going back
and i have a lot of listeners who are my
listenership excuse young and excused
male
and relative i would argue were kind of
relative to every other cohort and some
of it
is a good thing in overdue but relative
to other cohorts
young men are failing and that is
they're not making
they're not making as much progress as
some other cohorts
and i'm wondering what advice you have
or what advice you would give to your
younger self or what advice you would
give to
to young men kind of you know just
starting out in their career
in terms of their professional approach
and i'd love to hear your thoughts or
your learnings about trying to be
you know a good dad and a good husband i
think it's a massive
under discussed topic that
young men are failing in the united
states of america but it's true
uh and it's in the numbers i mean you
can see it uh
at every level one of the things i say
in my book scott
was that and i think you were raised by
a single mom that's right right yeah i'm
a child of a single immigrant mother who
lived and died a secretary our household
income was never more than
uh forty thousand dollars uh and a warm
hand of government literally
grabbed me by the scruff of my neck and
threw me forward
and i worry that that warm hand is no
longer as big and as caring as it used
to be
but yeah i'm the son of a single
immigrant mother yeah
so today 40 of
kids are born into
single parent households uh and 90 of
the time single parent household is
single mother
yep and if you look at the the data uh
little girls who grow up with single
moms actually have okay outcomes
um in part because girls are more
adaptable they're better at school
earlier
uh they've got a strong female role
model they see super mom
but if you have a little boy in that
setting um it turns out that little boys
and i i'm the father to two young boys
myself
so i can see why this is the case but
apparently little boys are more
sensitive to parental time and input and
the lack thereof
than little girls like they they they're
they're more
subject to uh variability that way
um and so the outcomes around boys
brought up by single moms there are more
adverse
academic progressions more behavioral
issues
and the data is not great um and
and to me a lot of the problems that
that we see
um like cascade from from there where
you send them to these schools that
aren't really equipped
for people at different maturation
levels and it turns out that boys often
mature at different
rates than whatever the grade level is
supposed to be
and then at the college level uh the
last i checked i think is something like
43 percent of undergrads are men like 57
70 of high school valedictorians are
young women now
think about that yeah so so so you have
uh you have boys and men coming of age
and then you have an economy that has
become increasingly punishing
and uninviting like it used to be if you
were a guy with a high school
um education you could get like a
factory job and like
you know union household middle class
life like all that stuff's gotten
decimated
you know we've gotten rid of four
million manufacturing jobs the rest of
it
um and then you have a culture that like
that looks at
men and being like hey whatever happened
it's your fault you know it's
like that it's like every room we walked
into for the last 400 years we've been
right and all of a sudden every room we
walk into right now we're wrong
so it's like crimea river but i do see
young men feeling like
kind of they feel like they're you know
they're in this nether netherlands right
now
and as a young guy myself i mean i
remember vividly when my company failed
in my 20s and like you know you're like
like down on your luck and your
confidence is shot um
it's hard because i at least speaking
for myself like you had this real
thirst to try and make something of
yourself and when it feels like you
can't make something of yourself you can
like eat yourself alive
humiliate like that yeah in my case my
failure was very public everyone knew
that i tried to start this company and
that it was a flop and that like
the rest of it so because you know if
you start something you
kind of have to tell everyone you're
doing it and then when it dies then like
everyone
sees it so it felt like for a while like
no one was calling me and the
the rest of it and i remember lying on
my floor being like
what did i do and like i owed this
hundred thousand in debt
um and i think it is something where
uh you know many many men are not being
or
americans generally but men i think to a
higher degree like there isn't like a
clear path forward
um and so you know like my guidance
um would be to focus on the things that
you know you can
control that will give you like at least
some form of
self-development or the worst case
scenario at least like comfort where
it's like in my case when things went
south in my
20s like i established some fitness
goals for myself i was like well
like sure i'm a failure but at least
i'll be a fit failure
[Laughter]
i'll have a six-pack
or it could be like something around a
relationship
where you know it's like you turn around
and say look most of my friends
like you know aren't calling me now but
you know this one friend is calling me
and so like i'm gonna try and like
um uh pay attention to the positives in
my life
try and learn i mean a lot of people who
listen to your podcast are trying to
develop their business savvy
and so that's something that i did like
i tried to find people who knew more
than i did which was everyone
and then learn from them one thing that
helped me a lot in that direction is
reading books
um i think podcasts are great but i
think reading books um
to me was like the best way to feel like
i got inside someone's head
um and was getting a bit of like
uh wisdom the single most concrete thing
that happened
for me positively and professionally um
and this is advice i'd give to anyone is
like just try and find someone
who uh is ahead of you on a path that
you
want and then just say like look i will
do anything under the sun for you i
don't care what
it pays or doesn't pay i don't care what
you assign me like i'll take out the
garbage i don't care
but just like my being uh are able to
like demonstrate my value to that person
in that
setting would be
setting me up for at least some degree
of development on the path that i wanted
um and so in my case after my company
died there was like a more
established entrepreneur who's like hey
join my my little company
and i just saw this guy and was like
this guy is someone that
i'd want to be when i grow up and so
like whatever this guy wants me to do
i'll do
um and so if you can find someone who
you look up to in that respect
um just try and add value for them in
any form
and then you'll find yourself becoming a
little bit more like them
over time what about any thoughts on
being a
a good husband and a good father i mean
like you know i mean it's a constant
struggle you know it's like you can be a
good dad one day and then the next dad
the next day like you know like uh be be
a
less exemplary parent um it's the same
being a partner
it's like you're married and i mean i'm
just like the luckiest guy to be married
to evelyn like she put up with so much
stuff
um and appreciates me for the things
that i do bring to the table
um and you know i just have to i tell
her i appreciate her as often as i tell
her i love her
and so a lot of a lot of the struggle
i've had to deal with
i think that many people can relate to
is just trying to be grateful
like because it's so easy to start
getting down on yourself
or your relationships and be like oh
like i have a document on my phone
that's literally it's like okay here are
the things i'm grateful for
and then anytime i see myself spiraling
in a negative way or like snapping at my
kid or like
snapping at um you know like someone who
doesn't deserve it i'll be like wait a
minute like
i i hadn't seen my kids in like months
and i missed them terribly and like now
i'm around them and i'm like
not appreciating it like you know like
you try and like get
get some perspective um and in my case
it's helpful to have a document i
actually refer to where it's like here
are the things i'm grateful for
and some of the things are stupid you
know some of the things are like oh i'm
really grateful for my
like uh for that pizza place i really
like chipotle i'm grateful for chipotle
every day
yeah yeah right you have chipotle on
your list you'd be like oh i love that
place like
good for that um so it's like appreciate
the little things and the big things and
in terms of your accomplishments
have some really easy wins for yourself
too it's like look i can't control my
professional path today but i can make
sure i get
like uh you know a little bit of nature
in or some push-ups in or whatever the
hell it is
like give yourself some things that you
are actually very very
achievable and basic and that could be
like appreciating chipotle
and what it i'm curious you're talking
about i think fitness is
i mean fitness is my antidepressant i
think it's something that young people
need to embrace at an early age for a
lot of reasons
what's your fitness routine
uh well in quarantine it's been a little
different
like like i i i had a weekly basketball
game
um that was like the centerpiece of my
mental health
um but now it's uh calisthenics
riding a bike um playing with the kids
good for you all right yang
for mayor mayor yang that's got a ring
to it
i don't know scott i i'm i'm coming off
so quickly i mean like yang for
president it's like yank for president
like
that sounded better that sounded better
i need i need to try on a different yang
4x
label uh for a little while to get a
mental fit it took me a little while to
have yang for president come off the tip
of my tongue but then eventually uh you
know it was chanted by
thousands and then i i really got into
it
well it sounds like if i do do it i'm
gonna have a world world-class uh
um a business mind uh like somewhere on
the advisory
i'm running i'm running your finance
committee and i'm in for the first 50
bucks
i'm in i'm in well scott whatever i do
uh will certainly lean on you for uh
guidance and insight because you are one
of the most incisive
and perceptive thinkers on this and
you're like a voice of real
humanity it's like i think that's what
sets you apart is there all these folks
who are embedded
in these institutions that aren't
willing to speak
plainly about what's going on within
those institutions
um but yeah we need to return to basics
in many ways and a lot of our
organizations have lost the thread
like these schools our government
leaders for sure
uh we're going to fix it um we don't
have a choice you and i because we
had kids and we have to try and clean up
this mess as much as we can
[Music]
do you wear clothes do you want to like
them
uh i i will wear clothes and you like
yeah i really like these outer known
clothes they send me
and i think like the there are a couple
of things i like about them
number one is they actually feel high
quality like you know it's
better than than the usual um off the
rack stuff
uh and i i have to say the fact that
kelly slater the pro surfer and 11 time
world champion
uh is behind this line actually just
makes me feel cooler like i feel like
i've got a little bit more
surfing coolness uh in my
life just by wearing these clothes and i
know they were made
in a responsible way it wasn't like you
know little kids getting their
knuckles broken or anything um so
if you want to check out these clothes
uh
that are made responsibly uh they look
great they feel great go to
outernown.com
today and enter my code yang at checkout
and you'll get 25
off your full price order that's
autonomous.com o
u t e r k n o w n dot com
and remember to use my code yang at
checkout for 25 off
check them out today i don't know.com
promo code yang
25 off you're gonna like them a lot
you think this is the easiest ad we
record i think it is because i actually
wear this stuff
and like i've recommended it to friends
off the show
i don't know this and this is one of the
this is one of the easy ones i think
totally i get compliments on them too
yeah i love this stuff
check it out i don't know.com 25 off
it's fantastic
check them out outernoon.com use promo
code yang
[Music]
do you have what is the action on what's
the call to arms we have the election
and
uh how many days away is it 100 days or
something um
what what's the call to arms what what
can young people
or anyone listening thinks you know i
want to help what do you think is the
most effective way
to help right now number one help
yourself i mean this is a terrible time
you know like we have to look out for
ourselves and like
and say like it's okay to be depressed
or stressed out and take a break
number two is help the people around you
in your own life right
because you know people are struggling
and if you have the wherewithal if you
can like contribute to
you know like for example there's like
someone you know who's like out of work
to be like look
like i i just venmo people randomly um
you know it's like
[Laughter]
no i have this i have this i have this
rule called or this
be a baller and that is when i was
growing up i had a bunch of crazy
jobs i was a box boy i was a bar back i
parked cars at the beverly wilshire
hotel i was a pool boy at the mondrian
hotel
and on a regular basis andrew some total
stranger
would give me 10 20 50 bucks and for if
you're at ucla and you're living on top
ramen and bananas
which i was during the summers you know
it was kind of life-changing it meant
you could go on a date it meant you
could have a full tank of gas which was
a luxury
and it just changed my it would change
it wouldn't change my life but it would
change my week
and i think being i call it being a
baller and that is
over tip if you're in a position where
you have some economic security you
don't need a lot
giving the delivery guy the woman
putting your food in the backseat of
your car whatever it is
giving them 10 20 50 bucks it can it can
literally be
uh life-changing for that moment and
it's so many people did it to me
you're in yeah so be a be a baller and
then if you want to try and make
uh changes at like a large scale level
my organization move humanityforward.com
um we've given out seven million dollars
in direct economic relief
uh so so that's been great we're trying
to help candidates
around the country who want to try and
solve problems
uh and then a bigger picture you know
and in my view we gotta get joe into the
white house and then
if then they'll be secretary yang of
something or other and then hopefully
and then scott on some advisory board
and then we'll we'll
get to work but it's not going to happen
by accident so we just got to go do it
i wonder and this is my advice to you i
think mayor
yang is a more influential role
if you're in the cabinet you're going to
have less impact across a broader
a broader population but you could
experiment with ubi
in certain boroughs you could i mean
basically president of you know
the 19th largest country in the world
versus being
being in the cabinet now i've decided
we're running we're running for mayor
andrew we're running for me
we will have further conversations about
this scott uh but thank you man there's
a first of many i i had a blast
and uh yeah we should make this
semi-regular because i learn
a lot from you every time yeah i
appreciate that andrew and like i said i
i think the most you know in the world
of academia what we're supposed
supposedly charged with is not being
right or wrong but catalyzing a
conversation
and you catalyze the conversation you
know ubi when i first heard it i thought
that makes no sense and i didn't like it
and i like immediately kind of
checked back to this notion of socialism
and then
the more i heard you speak the more it
really evolved my thinking around
what are creative solutions for moving
us forward
and leveling up some of our
disenfranchised
cohorts and kind of the economic
apartheid that i'd like to think
unwittingly we've ended up with in the
u.s so
anyways i'm in i'm planning our first
event i don't know what it's going to be
it's going to be a coffee clutch or a
virtual fundraiser just let me know when
you're announcing
thank you scott you'll be among the
first to hear and i i appreciate the
sentiment
you know it's like for me there's a
balance like with everything it's like i
appreciate everything i've done but
you know like i got to solve the problem
like you know we got to actually get
this thing across the finish line
because this country is falling apart
um and you know it's going to be people
like you and i that hopefully can help
pull it together you know more more you
than me but i appreciate it all right
brother thanks for the time uh
and uh we'll do this again and uh
like i said yang goyang thank you scott
appreciate the heck out of you all the
best of the family thanks brother hi
chris
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you